today is Cyber Monday the biggest day of
the year for online shopping according
to Amazon one of the most popular
purchases on their site today was this
sony flat-screen TV this was the most
popular purchase right there that's real
well that got me thinking this is also
real what was Emma's Ahn's least popular
Cyber Monday item and you can look it up
and I did I did look it up and this is
real it turns out it's this this is a
spray this is a spray that Norwegian
fishermen use to keep walruses away from
their show fish traps that's the bottle
that's shaped like a walrus it's only
$7.99 down from 239 dollars and look at
that only one has been purchased one and
then I find out they have a video ad
check this out roasted nuts
[Music]
yeah they sold 1k can you believe some
idiot bought it Andy
I sure can turns out this stuff gets you
incredibly high guys that's enough
that's enough thank you all right
[Music]
that's fine that's this this is called
this is called first show back after
holiday break
[Applause]
you